the market situation of course was the
main issue again just like the last five
councils we had it has dominated our
council meetings during our presidency
and still the situation in several
agricultural sectors especially the
dairy pig meat and fruit and vegetable
sectors continues to be worrisome today
the Commission has given an update on
price developments and on the
implementation of the support measures
taken we concluded although some of the
price developments we're heading in a
positive direction slowly we had to
conclude that most of the farm incomes
are still negatively affected by the
ongoing market situation and also our
economies they're all depending on a
strong and healthy agriculture so they
face difficulties because of that market
situation and we agreed that the
difficult situation is calling for
additional measures the council
concluded that an additional financial
package should be agreed upon as soon as
possible and it urged the Commission to
present an additional package in the
council of July and later on the
Commissioner Hogan stated that a
proposal will be on the table next July
at a council called on the Commission to
table a proposal that would include
measures to stabilize or structurally
reduce production in the dairy sector
financial support measures from member
states to restructure the dairy or pig
meat sectors or to structurally reduce
supply and with that giving the
flexibility to member states to target a
to either sector and to add specific
conditions like limiting support for
businesses that face liquidity problems
specific conditions that fits specific
circumstances in the Member States